[Music]
three two one action
welcome back to off-the-record where we
talk about what hey guys just putting my
head in this oh it's too attached
yeah can you not suffer your fingers oh
no I can't it's like brass knuckles
almost yeah you should wait on these two
fingers then don't tell me what to do no
but you should because don't tell her
what to do dude don't tell her what to
do
it's gonna break your finger she could
do that but then like it doesn't take
the other finger up no yeah oh it's
Opstal it is kind of well it is kind of
up you know I didn't know that this was
more an emphatic middle finger versus
this like keeping your hand open yeah I
used to do this I did this one time and
then TIFF was like you're just going I
don't flip people off enough to do one
or the other I only flip off my friend I
closed it yeah we go by this we go bye
bye love my friends like you find no
people go like this I don't think I've
ever been mad and did this you never did
that in the road what do you like this
yeah I'd do that for road rage I do that
if this tissue wouldn't come out of the
box and it's like stung like [ __ ] you an
outright object Gillian it's now when I
walk through the gym and I see people
I'm just like yeah I wouldn't do that to
some I don't know how's the gym now
since the co vide good I mean like how
is it the whole atmosphere is it
different is it clean it's nice oh don't
talk to me
yeah because now everything's on a time
limit so people just you really can't
talk to anyone cuz you have to get your
workout in so people just go in and out
did it change the feel of like the
barbell gym we're like everyone felt
more like you just chilling there
talking hanging out yeah like people
like oh yeah like there's always a
[ __ ] party going on yeah but it's
like whoa because they have the two-hour
time then right
it is a little bit more rush but people
still talk you know if people still oh
yeah hey guys it's kind of so it's more
like the night shift versus like the
high time shift like how it used to be
it depends cuz sometimes the night shift
is like super packed but even the night
shift people have more time because they
don't have a little work right after so
they can't chill but I think it's just
nobody's like kicking on the turf just
loiter as much yeah no lawyers also see
like I mean we have most of our gyms are
like pretty much fanatics so you have to
sign up for a two-hour block and then
people are already warming up outside so
they're actually coming to the gym early
they don't want to waste or two hours on
mobility or whatever so they're doing
that outside and I've also seen people
sign up for two back-to-back two hour
blocks so they're like okay I'm gonna
hit my legs in this two hours so they
can clean the gym for thirty minutes and
I'm gonna come back in for the next two
hour blocks to do like bench or
something
oh wait wait there's cleaning sessions
in between every two hours there's a
thirty minute
so people are supposed to clean their
own stuff which I do see and everyone's
really awesome I kill and then every two
hours we clean the whole gym do you guys
remember Newsome during like what the
July was saying how all the restaurants
and everything's we're gonna close right
did the were you guys cared about the
gyms closing or anything oh they're
gonna talk about the winery how his his
was open like everyone was calling his
ass out because he shut everything down
but then he owns a winery and everyone
was still able to be there he'd made a
bucket
it sounds like cuz he closed restaurants
and all yeah everyone feels like it did
like all the stuff some closed down
again I don't know because I feel like
it was at first and then they closed the
bars I don't know why we're bars even
open yeah I think it's kind of weird
that people are like taking less
precautions right now though even though
like we've had the most we've ever there
all her grocery stores were like oh yeah
you can only go one way down the aisles
now when you're in the grocery store
it's like it's like I don't care about
the floors well cuz I think so many
things opened up and they're like they
are talking about how things are gonna
close again but they're not talking
about like backwards there's so much
things going on the news that it just
gets like filtered out so it's not like
before where they're like that's the
only thing they talk about now they just
say like in one thing and then they skip
that's true it was about it not only
caught on that's one thing I feel like
in in whatever like presidential
discussions they should also bring in a
psychologist because when they're
discussing
they're discussing policies they're
thinking of it almost like in a vacuum
but like people get burnt our people
don't give a [ __ ] anymore right so they
also have to take that in consideration
like hey we can I don't think we can
have a plan that stretches three months
because statistics show anything I those
are the three months people to say [ __ ]
it I think they do do that there's an
actual psychologist brought the
advertise what I think they do do that
because that's the reason why they were
opening up like parks they were opening
up beaches but not letting people sit
they were just letting them go out Oh
put their mental health I mean I bet
they have like advisories and stuff like
they have advisors that help and sound
like they do because everything that
they come up with I'm like no one's
gonna follow that yeah and then I'm
right and I see it I'm like no one's
following it the whole be saying like
they let people go to the beach but
they're like you could swim
you could run but you can't so
understand yeah I'm like who the [ __ ]
gonna do that everyone's gonna sit on
Santa retired or some [ __ ] well maybe a
little is my mind though is like why are
we such a [ __ ] embarrassment like
Americans
yeah it's specially Americans it's all
you have the ban from like a lot of
European countries right now I mean I
Ron get it right right like we could
have beat this [ __ ] but everybody is
just not on the same page and I think
that's the disjointedness like because I
was in Europe while [ __ ] was closing
down they were [ __ ] precise dude they
were [ __ ] around I mean I felt you
feel it like when they shut down it
feels like everybody's running inside
right the thing is Dave you've they shut
down but everyone stayed calm orderly
yes they were human I mean like they
weren't [ __ ] idiots when hear when
they say we shut down people live ok
bump so I'm gonna go to my restaurant
I'm still gonna do this I'm still gonna
go there are idiots here they're not
they're not being Hubert in some things
and they go that sounds reasonable we're
gonna close down public gatherings no
more than 2 people 2 or 3 in walking
down the street to go grab groceries
everyone's in line like sure there might
be a shortage and then they're
communicating like from the government
and the citizens
it just seemed much more organized and
there was no fear mongering on the news
like people weren't panicking and
tripping out the [ __ ] citizens
everyone was like I this is what we
got to do they shut down borders and
then as I was leaving back I was like
America's nuts as soon as I get to the
[ __ ] Chicago Airport
it is so disorganized it is so [ __ ] up
dude and it dad way too much staff for
this area and this other area those way
too much people and not enough staff
I miss my flight oh and in the week
before that there was basically like
people trapped at the airport for over
ten hours
well America I think it's also the
rebellious nests is built into the
culture yeah we think about Spring Break
you think of like right if you go to
like a [ __ ] Taiwanese Spring Break
there ain't no girls doing that kind of
[ __ ]
South Korean Spring Break ain't no one
doing that [ __ ] like it's just America
is just that's [ __ ] donut if there's
an empty parking lot it's [ __ ] people
like you're not gonna be seeing that
[ __ ] and I don't like it yeah in a bunch
of other countries it's just that's just
American growing up at with like
immigrant parents it's like you kind of
like see like I see I see my parents
perspective like coming over and they're
kind of like look at these Americans and
it doesn't matter what race or
whatever's just the American like
rebellion this rebellion yeah it's it's
ingrained and I see interesting our
media it's in our movies the music [ __ ]
I mean I'm like that too I'm just as
[ __ ] dumb yep same yeah I was out
trying to [ __ ] break rules like
everyone can jog i'ma go skateboard then
and [ __ ] when they first announced
like the quarantine and stuff like
people were like oh this is gonna be
like a week or two weeks but then like
you start seeing the videos of people
like not abiding by that like people
still throwing like huge rallies or like
especially in Oakland like where I grew
up like there's a thing where people
just get in the streets and they like
drift cars like they call it ghost
riding and stuff like that so people
online they're like okay yeah but it's
gonna go to like August's temporary
people are like no it's not like that's
impossible
and we're they're doing it downtown -
yeah entire like block parties for me
because oh [ __ ] the streets are empty so
they're going to the biggest streets and
just straight-up busting Donuts all day
and that's like American style because
we can but like the countries that have
their [ __ ] together acting like that
museum Australia just shut back down
even though on the first one see like
open back up again and do you hear about
like how it broke out no so it was the
Americans know music I know one country
shut down but it was like American or
British that weapons party then like oh
but I'll surely I think it was like the
security guards is something of like the
hotels and stuff they were the ones like
breaking breaking quarantine and like
[ __ ] having orgies and [ __ ] blaming
Chinese people in Australia
yeah dude there's a lot of racism
against Asians everywhere yeah yeah yeah
yeah it started it started going bad
again so like Melvin is completely shut
down right now and like the neighboring
cities I shot that dude good for you for
calling it Melvin I thought that got it
Mel warning if I'm an American so I'm
saying Mel born commander that's the
correct way to pronounce it like what
Melbourne Florida right so in American
words no I mean the city of Melbourne
yeah Florida but in if you're fond of us
if you don't have it you can't call it
like you know when they say like zebra
it's actually prawns abre do you ever
feel like I do so that's how it's called
back leg you know Deidre and Deborah Oh
true true yeah I breath do you ever feel
like a douche though when you come back
from a different country and then you
feel like you got to correct someone
because that's not how they say it over
there
I don't correct them I'm not gonna
credit here Mel bin actually like when
I'm when I say it and like all [ __ ] I'm
that [ __ ] person cuz you gotta show
off and be like yeah you know back in
Melbourne no I'm not even thinking about
it like after I say I'm like oh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up I was quick little it's
Beijing do a lot to get them to
pronounce a record then obviously I'm
not gonna pronounce it properly the
right way first time around yeah I don't
care I don't care if they say like the
old English way pay king or [ __ ] Bay
jeez whatever I get what you're saying I
don't have to be like a stickler to like
the pronunciation especially Asian
people who have like especially the the
Asians that have intonation in their
language you're like nobody can
pronounce this correctly they're not
even gonna get close I'm not even gonna
correct well what about creamy products
though Oh cleaning products
because this off driver brought to you
by OxiClean damn awesome because it
cleans out all kinds of stains and you
know when you have a kid at home they're
spilling everything soy sauce peanut
butter maple syrup everything and with
the OxiClean max force it to spray it
tackles the toughest dried in stains
with five types of powerful stain
fighters it dissolves and traps grease
and oil lifts food stains from fabrics
binds to dirt and soil to suspend them
and rinse them away so if you have pets
it gets rid of that safe on colors so
unlike bleach you can use it on
everything and you can spray now and
wash up to seven days later so you could
just immediately when you come home
house still throw it on the hamper and
then to do your laundry when you need to
do it so y'all got a try OxiClean max
force for yourself to work your magic
with OxiClean go to OxiClean comm / max
force one to get a coupon for one dollar
off baby
so go ahead work your magic baby
OxiClean go OxiClean comm / max forced
one to get a coupon for one dollar
i'll link in the description box below
this is like youtubers do oh yeah they
do that they do this one man
so so so does that mean that Australia
is closed like nobody could come in no
it's not the entire country now its raw
what's this southern main part where
Melvin's in South Wales or some [ __ ] I
don't know
Queen Victoria New South Wales new South
Island
Gold Coast but anyway the safe that area
but wait New South Wales isn't that like
in Ireland or Europe oh well there's
Wales but then it's like you know they
got the same [ __ ] names for like
everything's British is [ __ ] yeah like
Queensland yeah like some [ __ ] like that
why they call Queensland not Queensland
booty call land blend their OS Demi just
over English is weird because if we do
that [ __ ] - up here saying we're gonna
see some a 19-5 Beach
right honey from Canada and because they
say like a water bottle water bottle
bottle so that they pronounce it
properly with Bo TT le and then the you
guys say Bo d le yeah York then it'd be
like nah water water on y'all or if
they're like a weirdo from Canada we say
Toronto Toronto Toronto oh my what shut
up
Ron's a nice city that's what I feel
like what you're saying like I feel like
a douche bag there cuz I'm like do the
two are so nice and you just feel like
oh [ __ ] I'm from America what do you
like about the rather just nice the
people do you ever pretend that you're
another culture just so they don't judge
you that you're American always well I
feel like there's so a mine judge either
they don't give a [ __ ]
no one I don't think anybody except for
like people that hate Korona
hate Japanese people well Japanese
people are so nice and so respectful
basis societies until they wanted until
they what until they make tentacle porn
and scare your children's hmm
people appreciate that overseas too
though the telescope horn I think every
everybody can be into it you have you
have you actually whitewashed it wait
yes you Joe that it's not my thing
my favorite is the teddy why cuz Joe is
he knows all corners of the porn world
like under the bed of the foreign world
he knows that like all this [ __ ] that's
hidden you know all orders so you're
saying that porn world is flat what are
you saying about the tentacles what I
want the tentacles I want to hear what
your no I was just gonna say that my
favorite is when I watched a Vietnamese
dubbed version oh my
Oh Ann its Doug - didn't I just get
hungry when I see tentacle when it's
insider [ __ ] or when it's outside oh
and I just feed octopus legs is the the
tentacle I wasn't taught there yaki male
the futures are I don't know it's
supposed to be the guy because it's
going in the girl what the one that I
watched I didn't even get to the
penetration part but it was like a
school look oh and in the tentacles
opens the shirt up of the chick tentacle
porn is as old as 1600 whoa in the
[ __ ] wood carving ones they've been
happening it's the worst when you're
watching like a anime or something and
all of a sudden they do the fan service
and they have like tentacle [ __ ] come
out of nowhere and you're like I'm just
trying to enjoy a normal ass [ __ ] ain't
homage they do they do I don't we do the
whole time they'll have like sometimes a
random episode where they just try and
do a bunch of fanservice well it's like
upskirting and like [ __ ] tentacles
all day playing and service yeah like I
say the moon upskirt true horny watching
you anime animation dealing hint I it's
like it's just like watching like
Pokemon you're like hi yeah yeah like
the skirts they wear is like hiked up in
like dang like well we got you feeling I
want to feel right now but just trying
to [ __ ] watch a show about robots and
I'm got a boner boner when things open
up what is the first place you're gonna
go you mean stores no countries oh well
this isn't a country because I want to
go to Hawaii soon because the governor
is opening up if you have a corona test
cutter net gonna test yeah if you have a
corona test at a CVS and it's a 72-hour
period
you go there show the paper say hello
male adder here ready to party America
like we're all topless no big deal
it was crazy about the test we'll say
like I have to go and like prove that I
don't have the virus but they don't make
you remove the mask do I check your
identity they just give them your ID and
all that stuff so you could technically
go do it for me you want to go to the
bank like they still ask for my ID but
then I'm really wearing a hoodie and a
mask yeah they don't like let me check
yeah you know what you know you know
where they do require your face the
phone don't play no games dude the phone
won't let you sell who's worse than a
bouncer man and Punk dirtier yeah the
phone will not make an exception but if
I'm wearing sunglasses it reads it
though well it depends on the tent is so
dark
yeah they're not that dark and it does
read it but it when they're super
blacked out and it won't realize
sometimes I got like I don't recommend
this but when I'm driving now you see
how it's like locked right now just go
like this I'll just like give it the
side I need I contact are you playing
what you're like doing experiments as
you drive no I just noticed like it
gives the eye contact to where like you
could see that it's not the second you
like you see a flasher eyes at it just
flash your eyes when you see the unlock
but if it was that easy would you want
them that much yes
what the [ __ ] are you answering for your
the flat earther you can't answer those
questions on Sumerian what were you
gonna do I'm gonna turkey like a few
days but where would you want to go but
you can go to Turkey are they as
quarantine as us well they haven't
opened up yet oh oh sure you just gamble
is hoping that what you're getting up
there and you just have to stay in your
hotel room the whole time
oh yeah I mean I'm on the beach so I
think you'll be fine but it's like they
open up on the 15th so I'm hoping that
they don't realize how bad America is
going and they're like they don't they
don't just let us knock I think they
know I'm pretty sure they know dude the
whole world kind of knows we're number
one yeah you have a quarantine where
Florida
to the world world yeah yeah we make for
the Florida but we're for Florida yeah
once I actually read a tweet that said
that was like oh it is true we are mad
but it's also the news that they get of
us okay with the good news then give
them some good ones well the news that
we get from our news stations are like
we care but everyday Americans aren't
like that you know I mean like the news
that they get of us is probably just
actual facts we are news even whatever
news station you watch is made to make
us wanna watch it yeah so it's just
crazy stuff that they want to push
that's true when I was when I was
watching the like the coverage on
coronavirus first and then after that
the whole BLM that BLM stuff like I was
watching Australian news to get more of
like that not so one-sided argument type
stuff yeah and I was like oh that's
really news channels are actually doing
a decent job with like just give me all
the facts I need right now and and then
it doesn't bow me up either it's just
like this is important to listen to and
that's cool you know that's true
American news got me pissed off all this
yeah I'm like oh look this thing or [ __ ]
that thing yeah whatever that thing you
know they're like a man saved 20 bunnies
today man
[Music]